well Android is Google's cell phone
operating system and I have they have
some beautiful demonstration videos on
their website and it's quite attractive
and extremely easy to use sort of iphone
like in its way and the really exciting
thing is that it is meant to be open it
is meant to be added on to and you're
supposed to pick programs that you like
and install them and you know the pro of
this is it'll make these phones much
more useful and personalizable and
interesting to the owners the downside
is they're turning into pcs they will
have to be trouble shot and they'll be
much more complex and who are you're
going to call when something doesn't
work